sie sagen wir dürfen Putin nichts
glauben
also wer das tut der ist naiv der lügt
doch sozusagen das klingt jetzt ein
bisschen platt wenn er nur den Mund
aufmacht wenn sie sich da ändern am 16
Februar glaube ich war es vorher sagte
kein Mensch würde daran denken in die
Ukraine einzumieren eine Woche später
war er drin oder damals bei der Krim wo
er gesagt hat damit haben wir gar nichts
zu tun und ein Jahr später lobte sich
selbst dass er das da so gut hingekriegt
hätte den Anschluss der Krim und man das
muss man wirklich sich vergegenwärtigen
diese KGB
Sozialisation die ist in der DNA dieses
Mannes das ist kein normaler Politiker
und was Amerika anbetrifft da würde ich
gerne noch einen Satz zu sagen
die Freiheit dass wir hier frei
diskutieren dürfen die haben wir den
Amerikanern zu verdanken stimmt und die
Freiheit dass wir nicht morgen selber
Opfer eines solchen Einmarsches sind
haben wir auch den Amerikanern zu
verdanken wir verteidigt uns denn wer
kann uns denn verteidigen diese
Bundeswehr mit ihren 235 Panzer wie mehr
nehmen wir mal einnehmen wir ein
Beispiel nehmen wir mal die
ostseepipelines nur als ein Beispiel es
ist ja noch nicht klar gesagt wer die
jetzt da wo die Sabotage war versteht
von vielen Experten das wasabotage aber
empfinden sie das nicht dass man darüber
zu spekulieren es ist wie bei einem
Raubüberfall wenn ich nicht beweisen
kann wer der Täter ist bräuchte auch gar
nicht
spekuliert das ist Russland war es wird
ja schon überall gesagt dass es Russland
war obwohl man nicht spekulieren sollte
ich weiß nicht wer das sagt das muss man
halt ermitteln da muss man auch die Zeit
sich für nehmen das ist nicht so ganz
einfach sicherlich war unter Wasser da
sind natürlich auch die Spuren nicht so
einfach
auf jeden Fall ist das ein
Terroranschlag das stimmt mich der Fürst
hinzu das ist ja offensichtlich
eindeutig so was kann man nicht so was
passiert nicht aus Zufall oder so etwas
und ich bin sehr gespannt dass wenn wir
sicherlich irgendwann alle auch erfahren
wer dafür letztlich die Verantwortung
trägt für die Toten in Butcher weiß ich
wer die Fahrt findet und dieser Mann
sitzt im Kreml absolut
und was würden Sie jetzt erwidern auf
diese sagen wir mal ja sehr harsche rede
also ich würde sagen natürlich sind wir
als Bürger überfordert die an einen
Krieg zu analysieren und über einen
Krieg ist immer etwas Schreckliches und
wenn zwei sich streiten freut sich der
Dritte es ist schrecklich und wir stehen
unmittelbar vor dem Ausbruch des Dritten
Weltkriegs das müssen wir uns bewusst
machen deswegen bin ich gegen jede
weitere Eskalation auch in der Rhetorik
der Medien weil ich habe das Gefühl dass
die Generation die heute schreibt und
berichtet dass der Krieg so weit weg ist
dass sie überhaupt nicht wissen worüber
worüber mit was sie da spielen mit
welchem Feuer denn am Ende des Tages
wird werden die Geschichtsbücher werden
sagen können wer war schuld bei welcher
Konsequenz bei welchem wann wie wo was
das beurteilen dann die Historiker aber
jetzt müsste unser aller Bestreben sein
Frieden zu stiften und dass bedeutet
dass der der Krieg aufhört weil
diese Milliarden aber mir ich glaube es
sind 140 Milliarden alleine damit
könnten sie dreimal Afrika sanieren
damit könnten sie Südamerika und Afrika
sanieren wird in diesen Krieg gesteckt
und die Ukrainer sterben die ganzen
Legionäre sterben die das ganze sowieso
am am Abgrund aber wir geraten mit in
den Abgrund weil wir ja auch das
bezahlen müssen das heißt das Geld für
unsere armen und für unser Bürger bleibt
ja gar nichts mehr übrig denn wir müssen
das Geld ja dann für die Waffen ausgeben
und für den Krieg der jetzt da weiter
druckt also in unserem Interesse ist es
jedenfalls alles zu tun um die Politiker
dazu zu bewegen egal wer angefangen hat
aufhören zu streiten der Krieg muss
beendet werden damit wir wieder wachsen
können sonst sehe ich erstmal den
wirtschaftlichen Niedergang mit großer
Armut und und und und schrecklicher
Krise aber viel schlimmer noch der
dritte Weltkrieg und wie ein nuklearer
Winter aussieht da wird es fünf Jahre
lang nicht mehr hell da wird das
eskalieren
das wird nicht dazu kommen
putin wird sich hüten mit der NATO sich
hoffentlich nachdem nach der Performance
Designer Armee da jetzt schon hingelegt
hat also das wird mit Sicherheit ihr
Wort in Gottes Ohr aber wir spielen mit
dem Feuer ich würde eine Zwischenfrage
gerne an Sie stellen Herr lute und zwar
el mask der heißt ja jetzt gerade
aufgefallen das haben sie wahrscheinlich
mitbekommen medial dass er
zufriedensverhandlungen aufgerufen hat
dann auch noch auf Twitter hat abstimmen
lassen aber nehmen wir mal die Forderung
nach Friedensverhandlungen wie haben sie
das eingeschätzt von Elon Musk können
Sie die medienschädel vielleicht auch
von der Füße nachvollziehen die sie
angebracht hat also
äußert sich ja gerne sehr kontrovers
aber ist damit auch zumindest in der
Lage Themen sag mal in den medialen
Markt zu drücken und das ist an der
Stelle meines Erachtens völlig richtig
ich bin nicht der Auffassung des Herr
Butin ein so außergewöhnlicher Typus des
Politikers ist sie sagen man darf ihm
nicht glauben er lügt ich erinnere an
Norbert Blüm Norbert Blüms die Renten
sind sicher beispielsweise oder auch an
die Situation
grundsätzlich immer alles die Frage ist
was man gleich setzt und was man nicht
gleichsetzt ich glaube auch immer besser
machen
genau das wollte ich gerade als zweites
Beispiel anführen aber es gibt eine
Legion solche Beispiele in allen
Bereichen die Wahrheit ist das was als
allererstes geopfert wird im politischen
das ist doch genau das Problem also
insofern ist der Boot in erstmal nichts
anderes was wichtig ist an jeder Stelle
ist miteinander zu reden ich habe im
Parlament immer dafür geworben dass ich
an jeder einzelnen Stelle mit jedem
Kollegen egal aus welcher Fraktion ein
Dialog führe weil das unsere Aufgabe ist
zu vermitteln und letztlich dann reden
ist ja jeder bei ihnen glaube ich also
ich glaube keiner hier am Tisch würde
nein wenn ich von vorne rein sage mit
dem kann man doch nicht reden dann bin
ich natürlich nicht beim Reden dabei und
die spannende Frage ist doch noch eine
ganz andere
da können sie nicht mehr mit ihm reden
da können sie sich nur verteidigen
vollkommen in der akuten Situation
und wenn sich Diplomaten Treffen findet
das auch ohne Waffen statt das ist nicht
die Situation im übrigen ist es viel zu
kurz gedacht was passiert denn jetzt
wenn der Putin Weg wäre wer kommt dann
raus dann haben sie den dritten
weltkriegt
dass die Nationalisten in Russland Putin
vor sich her treiben heute schreibt
sogar die neue Züricher zeitungsweise
habe ich mich sehr gewundert weil ich
mir auch gedacht habe woher nehmen die
Amerikaner die Naivität zu glauben dass
es nach Putin besser wird wir haben in
Russland eine sehr sehr starke viel
extremere Fraktion da ist auch der
ausgeglichenste wer sagt uns denn das
nachher aber wie soll beispielsweise
wollen aber genau wie im Irak oder in
Afghanistan es ist nichts gekommen
Zwischenfrage ich denke dass ich alle am
Tisch einig sind das Diplomatie
selbstverständlich gut wäre wenn es
funktioniert
sie denn beispielsweise auf die
scheinreferenten reagieren damit ist
Putin jetzt noch einen weiteren Schritt
Richtung Eskalation gegangen wir haben
ja auch ein Referendum gehabt im Kosovo
und die Kosovo Albaner haben ihre ihre
Autonomität
bekommen die sind auch von den
Amerikanern und uns anerkannt geworden
nichts anderes wollte der Don Bass der
Donbass wollte gar nicht weg von der
Ukraine der Donbass wollte nur weiter
russisch sprechen dürfen es wäre genauso
wenn Sie den Genf von sagen würden sie
dürfen nicht mehr französisch sprechen
von heute das ist sogar
sehr gerne Herr traban machen sie das
wahrscheinlich ich weiß nicht wer schon
in der Ukraine jetzt war ich war in der
Ukraine ich war in Kiew in Liv in
Butscher in erbien in viscorod ich habe
mit den Menschen vor Ort gesprochen ich
war an dem Massengrab in butja
das ist alles natürlich unheimlich ja
das macht betroffen die Menschen sind
betroffen die Menschen sind total
irritiert
wichtig ist dass wir nicht der Ukraine
vorzuschreiben haben was sie jetzt
verhandelt das muss die Ukraine selbst
machen ja
wichtig ist auch dass Demokratien
Demokratien unterstützen deshalb ist es
wichtig dass wir die Ukraine
unterstützen aber es muss immer das Ziel
sein dass es wieder zu einem Frieden
kommt aber das muss die Ukraine mit
Russland verhandeln und ich möchte in
dem Zusammenhang einfach auch noch mal
deutlich machen
Demokratien müssen nach außen geschützt
werden ja aber Demokratien müssen auch
im Inneren geschützt werden und das ist
ja das Thema für dass ich mich einsetze
dass gerade jetzt bei diesen fehlenden
finanziellen Ressourcen zu wenig an
Menschen gedacht wird die von Armut von
Ausgrenzung von Benachteiligung
betroffen sind und wenn ich Menschen
nicht mehr in die Mitte der Gesellschaft
zurückhole wenn ich sie nicht jetzt
unterstütze dann gehen sie für das
Modell der Demokratie verloren und das
bedeutet wir müssen Demokratien im
Inneren sichern indem wir etwas für
soziale Gerechtigkeit das Thema von
ihnen kommen wir gleich noch wir bleiben
noch einmal bei der kleinen Russland den
Konflikt aber das ist mir einfach jetzt
schon mal wichtig darauf hinzuweisen
sonst werden nämlich die Menschen
empfängliche für Rechtspopulisten
Rassismus und
ja danke Sahra Wagenknecht ist jetzt
nicht die Partei DIE LINKE das beurteile
ich überhaupt nicht ich bin parteilos
ich habe aber Sarah Wagenknecht ist im
Gegensatz zu ihnen bei den Linken ja ja
das ist richtig aber zu Putin noch man
zur Wahrheit gehört eben auch ja ohne
irgendetwas beschönigen zu wollen dass
die NATO dass der Westen viele
Hinweise Russlands
negiert hat das immer Genscher hat schon
Russland zugesichert die Ukraine wird
nicht in die NATO kommen wird nicht
in die West Erweiterung aufgenommen auch
andere Länder nicht aber dennoch ist das
geschehen also das war auch ein
Fehlverhalten das das rechtfertigt
nichts und diese Heuchelei jetzt die ich
auch empfinde in in dieser Diskussion
dass ein Nato-Partner der jetzt
vermittelt die Türkei dass die Türkei
einen völkerrechtswidrigen Krieg gegen
die kurten in Nordsyrien führt dass dort
in der Roger Region Krankenhäuser
zerstört werden die Infrastruktur
zerstört wird ich war in roger war ich
war in kobane und dort ist jetzt eine
Choleraepidemie eine
meningitis-epidemie und keiner kein
deutscher Politiker kümmert sich um
diese Situation wo eben auch das
Völkerrecht gebrochen wird von einem
Nato-Partner also auch müssen wir
intervenieren die Menschenrechte müssen
überall zählen die zählen für Putin aber
auch für Erdogan und für andere ein
schönes Stichwort da würde ich gerne
einmal Herr Knabe Fragen sind wir da
heuchlerisch 10 nicht die Menschenrechte
überall gleich für uns
tja das ist eine schwierige Frage
letztlich ist die Gültigkeit von
Menschenrechten abhängig von der Macht
die hinter dem jeweiligen Regime steht
wir brauchen nur nach China zu schauen
wo die Uiguren in den Lagern sitzen oder
nach Belarus wo der Herr Lukaschenko den
Schutz von Herrn Putin genießt
da werden die Menschenrechte tausendfach
verletzt das heißt ich werde nie
vergessen wie dieser Lukaschenko den
Mann da oben aus dem Flieger von Ryanair
geholt hat das ist doch unglaublich den
vom Himmel zu holen aus dem Flugzeug
raus der flog glaube ich von
Griechenland nach Finnland oder so was
und es passiert nichts weil eben darf
man Angst kein Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft
in Katar stattfinden ja genau also der
Westen kann schon auch sich
positionieren muss ich positionieren ich
bin ein großer Freund für und der
Universität der Menschenrechte ich will
nur auf einen Punkt kurz dahin weisen
Herr Trabert wo ich denke dass sie sich
da auch selbst widersprechen wenn sie
sagen dass die Ukraine über ihre eigenen
Belange selbst entscheiden können muss
da beginne ich wenn ich ganz davor dann
hat sie auch das Recht zu entscheiden wo
sie sich militärpolitisch einordnet im
Westen im Osten oder irgendwo dazwischen
und das gilt für alle diese Staaten die
früher von Russland dominiert wurden
oder von der Sowjetunion
bin auf dem Baltikum gewesen und habe
nie verstanden warum die immer gesagt
haben die EU das ist uns gar nicht so
wichtig wir wollen in die NATO ich
dachte was haben die denn davon jetzt
ist mir das klar was Sie davon haben
nämlich eine relative Sicherheit dass
Herr Putin dort nicht einmarschieren
wird weil dann eben die gesamte
verteidigungsallianz da für sie
verteidigen oder hoffentlich ein Gedanke
wäre fällt mir da ein da ich könnte ich
wäre bei ihnen ich habe nie verstanden
warum man nicht Russland auch in die
NATO aufgenommen hat dann hätten wir
nämlich aber das war der große Fehler in
diesem Kooperationsrat gehabt alle
Probleme los gewesen wir hätten woran
ist es gescheitert damals mit Russland
das liegt einfach daran dass der KGB in
Russland im Jahr 2000 die Macht
übernommen hat so einfach ist das Herr
jetzchen mit Herrn Gorbatschow war das
alles zu verhandeln und das
ja also der hätte doch der gommerschaft
hätte doch auch die Panzer hier bei
ihnen hinterm Haus auffahren lassen
können 1989 heißt der demonstriert weil
es wäre doch gar kein Problem gewesen
500.000 sowjetische Soldaten waren hier
die hätten das mit Links erledigt hat er
nicht gemacht auch Jelzin hat immer
wieder diese demokratischen Prinzipien
hoch gehalten und dann
hat man ihn da unter Druck gesetzt dass
er irgendwelche
Kreditkarten benutzt hätte die ja nicht
hätte benutzen dürfen aus dem Westen und
dann hat man gesagt du musst jetzt
abtreten und wir haben hier einen der
setzt das fort was du so eigentlich
vorhast nämlich den Herrn Putin und da
hat man sich im unendlich getäuscht und
das hängt dann eben doch lieber Herr
Ludwig sie sind Frage wie man ich rieche
das wenn ich das so sagen darf uns ist
unterscheidet sie auch prinzipiell von
einem KGB Mann dass sie Werte haben es
kann sein dass sie vielleicht auch mal
Lügen was Politiker aber es gibt Grenzen
das Recht ist eine Grenze die
Menschenrechte sind eine Grenze und
diese Grenzen kennt ja Putin nicht und
hat da glauben sie ist nicht Russland
das möchte ich auch nochmal anschauen
das russische Volk ist doch wesentlich
auch differenzierter zu bewerten nicht
jeder Russe unterstützt Putin wie mutig
die Menschen jetzt auf die Straße gehen
es sind schon über 200.000 Männer durch
die teilmobilisierung geflohen quasi
100.000 nach Kasachstan 66.000 in die EU
das ist ja Proteste junge russische
Soldaten im Krieg richtig aber ich mir
ist es nur wichtig dass man auch nicht
Russland über einen Kamm schert aber
gibt es auch demokratische Bewegungen
die von Putin erstickt wurden
systematisch vollkommen richtig aber
Russland ist viel bunter Multiplayer
heterogener als ihr jetzt so finde ich
diskutiert wird aber die Zustimmung für
Vladimir Putin in Russland ist jetzt
nicht bei Null das kann man jetzt ja
keine freie Presse ja woher bekommen die
Menschen die Informationen und dennoch
gehen so viele in meinen Augen viele auf
die Straße dennoch riskieren sie ihr
Leben um diesem Diktator
entgegenzutreten also da ist viel
demokratisches Gespür in diesem Volk
würde ich sagen es wird aber unterdrückt
permanent unterdrückt und in eine
Diktatur sich demokratisch zu äußern
dafür sich einzusetzen das ist halt mit
dem Leben bedroht er hat das möchte ich
einfach ich möchte auch ein Plädoyer für
diese
russischen Menschen einfach hier noch
mal deutlich
äußern ja das ist mir das ist mir zu
sehr unterstreichen das dauert ich
möchte kurz eine Geschichte erzählen ich
habe
besten Freund der ist Leiter des Gulag
Museums in Moskau
und dem habe ich vor ein paar Tagen
geschrieben wenn ich irgendwie helfen
kann sagt bescheid ich hatte mich hatte
das immer vorzuschreiben ob das da lange
nicht gemacht vor mir hingeschrieben was
meinen Sie was das bei dem ausgelöst hat
der hat gesagt er hat es allen seinen
Mitarbeitern vorgelesen diese drei Sätze
per WhatsApp und
bekam plötzlich den Eindruck der fühlt
sich wie ein Aussätziger nur weil er
Russe ist keiner redet mehr mit ihm die
Kollegen von früher alle tauchen ab
wollen nichts mehr mit ihnen zu tun
haben aber das ist eben es gibt auch ein
anderes Russland was mit Herrn Putin
nichts am Hut hat würde ich einmal gerne
Fragen Füße in der Kontakt zwischen
Russland und Deutschland kann man ja
schon sagen ist ja abgebrochen also es
funktioniert ja kein wirklicher
diplomatischer Weg mehr müssten die
deutschen Politiker vielleicht noch mal
hin fliegen wenn das überhaupt möglich
wäre naja man muss so sagen durch diese
Explosion der Gouda die Zerstörung der
Gaspipeline sind unsere Möglichkeiten
jetzt doch wieder mit Russen ins
Geschäft zu kommen vernichtet das heißt
wir sind jetzt wirklich energiepolitisch
auf uns selbst gestellt und deswegen
müssen wir natürlich zügig unsere
eigenen Anlagen wieder anschmeißen
es ist das sehr bedauerlich weil wir
natürlich als Europäer und auch wenn man
das geschichtlich betrachtet es ist ein
tausendjähriges Reich wir haben enge
Verwandtschaft mit Russland man hätte
Russland viel näher an uns anbieten
dürfen das möchten die USA aus
strategischen Gründen was ich aus USA
Sicht verstehen kann ich verstehe die
Amerikaner man möchte nicht einen
dritten Machtblock Europa und Russland
das da könnte schon und das hat sich ja
jetzt auch gezeigt durch den
Wirtschaftsaufschwung und durch die
Beziehungen die wir mit Russland an der
hätte ein selbstständiger Machtblock
entstehen können dann hätte man hätten
die Amerikaner nicht nur die Chinesen
sondern plötzlich werden auch die
Europäer selbstbewusster geworden hätte
ja auch mehr Geld gehabt und mehr mit
mit einem großen gemacht das war ja
schon vor dem Ersten Weltkrieg machen
immer gesagt der Russe hat die Rohstoffe
der deutsche die Intelligenz beides
zusammen ist unschlagbar das darf nicht
passieren
als ob wir die müssen sich genauso
intelligent wie die Ukrainer und ich
spreche jetzt über Geopolitik da ist
jetzt nicht so zwischenmenschliche
Beziehung sondern in der Geopolitik geht
es erstmal um Macht und natürlich hätte
ein starkes solch eine Russland Arbeiter
besser ausgebildet als der
durchschnittlich russische Arbeiter
natürlich
gerade zu tun Intelligenz gemeint mein
Gott also gerade legen sie doch nicht
jedes Wort auf die Goldwaage das ist das
ist eine Form der Diskriminierung
gesprochen Russland können wir nicht
über einen Kamm scheren
interessanterweise schieren wir ja jetzt
an jeder Stelle die Ukraine über einen
Kamm anscheinend jeder der Ukraine ein
großer Freund dieses wir verhandeln
nicht wir wollen ein letztlich totalen
Krieg dass die der ukrainische Präsident
gerade vertritt und das wird mit
Sicherheit auch nicht die Meinung von
100% der Ukrainer sein die Geprügel und
die müssen
noch mal wir sprechen hier von
Differenzierung das müssen wir dann
bitteschön an der anderen Seite ganz
genauso betreiben natürlich und insofern
kann man auch nicht sagen lass die doch
selbst was die Ukraine wirklich wollen
muss ja nicht zwingend das sein was der
Präsident in dieser Situation verkündet
vielleicht fehlt hier bei 8:15 Uhr
einfach der diversity überhaupt
keine anderen
abgeschafft der er hat die Fernsehsender
abgeschafft die den er nicht haben will
und er hat auch die Parteien verboten
also wie man in der Ukraine von
Demokratie sprechen kann ist eigentlich
ein Witz weil das ist ein von von
Oligarchen die international vernetzt
sind geführtes Land die auch mit die
Familie beiden sitzt mit dem Boot also
da das ist natürlich gerne hier würde
ich gerne einmal Herr knabes Expertise
ganz kurz hören mit dem Vorwurf mit dem
Vorwurf ob man über die Ukraine sagen
kann dass es keine Demokratie ist also
nach meinem Eindruck hat sich die
Ukraine sehr in Richtung Demokratie
entwickelt das war vor ein paar Jahren
noch ganz anders da war noch die KGB
Leute da überall im Geheimdienst in der
Ukraine und dafür gab zwei Zäsuren das
war einmal waren die die Kundgebungen
auf dem Maidan das erste Mal und dann
gab es einen Schub der Aufarbeitung und
dann das zweite Mal 2014 der europame
protestet übrigens damals auch ja und
vor allem das hat die haben das Land
total verändert ich habe mich länger mit
der Aufarbeitung selbstkommunismus
beschäftigt und nach 2014 geht das
plötzlich los dass sie anfangen zu
feiern was ist denn mit diesen ganzen
lehnins die hier rumstehen finden Sie
das Gut in jeder Stadt Leni zu haben
sich ja auch nicht weil es ein
Massenmörder ist der da nichts verloren
hat dann haben sie angefangen diese
linienstatuen abzubauen 5000 Stück gab
es in der Ukraine wirklich in jedem Kaff
oder Sie haben die
angefangen die die Beamten zu überprüfen
ja was haben die eigentlich gemacht
früher und vor allem wer von denen seit
2014 diese Gesetze wo zum Beispiel ein
sich neu bewerben musste um Richter sein
zu dürfen und bevor er da oder als hätte
wenn er das tat musste er seine
Einkommensverhältnisse offenlegen und
vor allem deutlich machen was hat er
verdient und was besitzt er und da gab
es eben bei vielen Richtern riesige
Unterschiede die waren steinreich um das
mal Platz zu sagen das will Korruption
bekämpft und deswegen haben 2000 Richter
sich gar nicht erst wieder beworben das
ist ein riesen Fortschritt in Richtung